if my phone got hacked you won't find
anything interesting unless you like
creepy window dressings and the shoes I
wish I could pull off but after some
very private pictures of a list
Hollywood celebrities were leaked online
Twitter was aflutter with the hashtag if
my phone got hacked an anonymous user
dumped a stash of stolen nude photos of
celebrities on the internet message
board fortune actors Center for Lauren's
model Kate Upton and singer Ariana
Grande to name a few and even though
some celebrities say the photos of them
are fake this whole thing has brought
the neverending issue of online privacy
back to the forefront Carol Jones
tweeted what many have been thinking
newsflash
if you don't want nude photos leaked on
the Internet then don't take them or
take them with a film camera but some
took issue with that idea in Esquire
article Luke O'Neill writes this sort of
thing is a form of victim blaming that
puts all of the shame on the women in
question and none on those who are
actually at fault Mike Biffle tweeted if
my phone got hacked guilt would lay with
the hacker and the hacker alone I would
hope smart arses would empathize and not
start hashtags but most sweeps gave the
hashtag a lighter spin Angelina Boras
speeded if my phone got hacked you would
only find hundreds of failed selfie
attempts Brandon Bennett says if his
phone was hacked it wouldn't matter I'm
so old school my nudes are on Polaroids
and there have been a lot of ridiculous
pictures mostly as pets but Nate shank
reminded us that Hollywood is what makes
these hacks special tweeting this photo
no one wants your nudes but even though
the things that the hackings are celebs
they're still victims who didn't give
their consent to be exposed and they're
almost all women only one of a hundred
names of the hacker published as targets
was a guy prompting Roxane gay to write
in The Guardian that targeting these
women is actually a sexist way of
reminding them of their place in society
don't get too high in my tea ladies your
bared body can always be used to shame
and humiliate you actress Mary Winstead
fired back at anyone snooping at her
pics
tweeting to the
of you looking at photos I took with my
husband years ago in the privacy of our
own home hope you feel great about
yourself unfortunately I think some
internet trolls feel just fine subscribe
on YouTube follow us on Twitter and like
us on Facebook